-Sophie Nordmann,
vous êtes philosophe, spécialisée
dans la philosophie juive.
Au-delà ou à côté,
vous avez construit
une "Phénoménologie
de la transcendance".
Titre qui peut faire
un peu peur,
mais qui, en même temps,
porte en lui une tension
qu'on va essayer d'expliciter,
ainsi qu'une promesse.
Nous traversons
une crise climatique,
une crise
civilisationnelle,
qui semble précisément appeler,
non pas des solutions isolées,
mais un changement global,
autrement dit,
un changement de paradigme.
La tâche est immense.
Est-ce que c'est celle
de la philosophie ?
Pouvez-vous expliquer
ce qu'est un paradigme ?
-Vaste question.
Un paradigme,
c'est, je dirais,
un cadre de pensée global
dans lequel
va venir s'exercer
la rationalité
et dans lequel prennent place
toutes sortes de débats,
de controverses,
d'oppositions,
de discussions,
mais qui ne vont jamais
remettre en question
le cadre lui-même
dans lequel
s'exerce
cette rationalité.
Disons qu'un paradigme,
c'est peut-être ça,
ce cadre ininterrogé.
Sans doute, la crise
que nous traversons aujourd'hui,
on le sent bien
appelle à un changement
de paradigme.
C'est-à-dire qu'il s'agit
d'une crise très globale
qui se décline
en une multiplicité d'aspects
et pour laquelle
on voit bien
qu'il n'est pas possible d'apporter
des solutions locales
mais qu'il s'agit d'une crise
à laquelle la réponse ne peut être,
elle aussi, que globale
et ça serait donc
précisément cela,
un changement de paradigme.
-Alors, vous vous inscrivez plutôt
dans une philosophie critique,
à l'enseigne de Kant.
Est-ce qu'on peut déjà
porter un diagnostic
sur cette crise
et donc sur ce changement
de paradigme ?
-La crise écologique
est un aspect
vraiment très massif,
mais n'est qu'un des aspects
de la crise
que nous traversons aujourd'hui.
Mais si on devait peut-être
caractériser la crise écologique
en regard
de cette question du paradigme,
alors peut-être
qu'effectivement
on pourrait dire
que la crise écologique
est, d'une certaine manière,
le symptôme
d'une crise
du paradigme moderne,
du paradigme
de la modernité.
Ce que je veux dire,
c'est qu'on peut
repérer la naissance
d'un nouveau paradigme
au tournant, je dirais,
du 17e siècle,
à l'époque d'un autre changement
de paradigme,
d'un changement
d'un paradigme cosmologique
qui est le passage
du géocentrisme,
du monde clos,
du cosmos clos,
à l'univers infini,
pour reprendre le titre
de la célèbre étude
de Koyré,
qui a signifié
un bouleversement cosmologique
absolument énorme
et, pour l'homme,
une perte
de tous les repères.
C'est-à-dire que là où l'homme
se sentait chez lui
comme le dit Hannah Arendt,
dans un cosmos harmonieux, ordonné,
où chaque chose avait sa place,
et l'homme également,
il se retrouve perdu,
comme un grain de poussière
sur une planète qui est elle-même
un grain de poussière
dans un univers infini.
C'est une désorientation
absolument totale,
comme si le monde perdait
son centre de gravité.
L'homme, d'un coup,
ne sent plus chez lui
dans le monde
et perd tous les repères.
Or, où est-ce que l'homme
va retrouver ses repères ?
A partir de quel ancrage
il va pouvoir reconstruire
sa vision du monde
et, donc,
reconstruire un nouveau paradigme,
pour employer ce terme ?
Cet ancrage,
il va le retrouver en lui-même.
C'est comme ça
qu'on peut comprendre
le très fameux "je pense
donc je suis" de Descartes.
Première certitude,
que même les plus extravagantes
superstitions des sceptiques
ne peuvent ébranler,
"premier roc solide,
point d'Archimède",
et Descartes lui-même
en parle en ces termes,
à partir duquel
l'homme va pouvoir venir
reconstruire
toute sa vision du monde.
C'est le paradigme
qui se construit à partir de là
qu'on peut qualifier,
me semble-t-il,
de paradigme moderne.
Or, qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire
que l'homme reconstruit
son paradigme à partir de lui-même ?
Ca veut dire
qu'il se pose
dans sa différence
par rapport à tout le reste,
à tout le reste du monde.
C'est peut-être là
qu'on peut voir...
aussi l'origine
de ce qui va devenir
la crise écologique
parce que, du coup,
par contrecoup,
en miroir,
le monde et les ressources
naturelles,
mais y compris
les animaux,
tout ce qui n'est pas
de la pensée,
tout ce qui n'est pas le cogito,
va devenir pour l'homme
de la matière et une ressource
exploitable à l'infini.
C'est ça qui ouvre
peut-être
la possibilité même
de ce qui va devenir
la crise écologique.
Et aujourd'hui,
on est,
avec la crise écologique,
face à une crise globale
de l'ensemble
de ce paradigme-là.
-Vous parlez
du sujet cartésien,
on va dire
plus globalement
de l'homme.
La question de l'homme est aussi
ancienne que la philosophie.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle a de nouveau,
dans le paradigme moderne ?
-Alors oui,
la question de l'homme
est une question aussi vieille
que l'homme lui-même,
peut-être aussi vieille
que l'humanité,
néanmoins, cette idée que l'homme
soit radicalement différent
du monde, qui est d'un côté...
C'est la phrase de Descartes :
"Pendant que je voulais ainsi
penser que tout était faux,
"il fallait bien que moi,
qui le pensais,
"je sois quelque chose."
On a le tout, et le moi,
et c'est cette séparation-là
qui est très nouvelle.
L'homme s'est toujours interrogé
sur sa propre humanité,
mais quand Aristote définit l'homme
comme un animal doué de logos,
il ne le sépare pas
du reste des êtres vivants
et il l'inscrit
dans le cosmos.
L'homme a une différence spécifique,
il est doué de logos,
mais néanmoins,
il appartient au cosmos.
Ce qu'il y a de très nouveau
avec le paradigme moderne,
c'est cette distinction radicale
entre l'homme et le monde,
entre l'homme et le reste.
-Alors vous montrez en même temps
qu'à partir du 17e siècle,
cette question de l'homme,
elle se scinde
en deux grands courants,
en quelque sorte.
Quelles deux grandes définitions
de l'homme vont s'affronter,
et continuent de structurer
notre champ de pensée ?
-Tout à fait,
parce qu'avec le cogito,
Descartes donne
le coup d'envoi
de ce paradigme moderne
qui va se déployer
à partir de lui.
Donc il y a une première ligne
de forces qui traverse la modernité,
mais il y en a
une deuxième,
qui est presque
concomitante.
Une génération
après Descartes,
on a un des plus grands lecteurs
de Descartes, qui est Spinoza,
et qui va précisément
contester
ce qu'on peut appeler
cette différence ontologique
que pose Descartes
entre l'homme et le monde,
et qui va au contraire
réinscrire l'homme
dans le tout,
dans ce qu'il appelle la substance,
dans la nature,
et contester
l'idée que le cogito soit
d'une nature différente
de tout le reste.
-On a Descartes versus Spinoza ici.
-Oui.
-Battle.
Et d'une certaine manière,
Descartes est le père
de la modernité,
Spinoza aussi,
mais d'une autre modernité,
qui est celle qui consiste,
par la rationalité
scientifique,
à inscrire l'homme
dans le monde,
et qui va contester
cette séparation radicale.
Et c'est ça aussi,
la crise du paradigme moderne.
C'est qu'on est pris
dans les tirs croisés
de ces deux lignes de forces,
et on en peut choisir
ni l'une ni l'autre,
parce qu'on est très attachés
à l'idée que l'homme
soit différent des autres êtres,
qu'il ait
une dignité particulière
qu'il mérite
un respect absolu...
-Ce qui fonde
les droits de l'homme
et une certaine conception juridique
des droits subjectifs.
-Et d'un autre côté,
on est très attachés aussi
à toutes les études scientifiques
et à cette rationalité scientifique
qui convergent vers l'idée
que l'humanité est
une forme d'être du monde
au même titre
et parmi les autres,
et c'est ce qu'on retrouve...
La première conception,
celle qui distingue
l'homme du monde,
c'est celle qu'on retrouve
quand on parle
de l'humanité en l'homme
qui lui donne
une dignité particulière.
Et la deuxième conception,
celle qui est plus héritière
d'une filiation spinoziste,
c'est celle qu'on trouve
quand on parle
d'un animal humain,
ce qui veut pas dire
que l'homme
se réduise à son existence
biologique.
Spinoza ne conteste pas
que l'homme ait
une rationalité,
mais en revanche,
sa rationalité
ne le met pas
sur un plan
radicalement différent
de tout le reste.
Et on est
très attachés aussi
à cette idée
que l'homme moderne
se serait mis lui-même
sur un piédestal
de manière un peu arrogante
et qu'il faudrait
l'en faire descendre.
Donc on est attachés
à ces deux modernités à la fois,
et elle est là aussi, la crise,
et c'est ça aussi qui fait
qu'on ne peut en sortir
qu'en sortant
du paradigme lui-même,
et pas en alimentant
une de ces modernités
contre une autre.
-Alors comment on en sort ?
-Alors, comment on en sort ?
On ne peut en sortir
- et là, je vais encore
suivre Kant -,
qu'en mettant au jour
ce qui fait la racine
de l'antinomie.
J'imagine que vous allez
me demander...
-Quelle est la source
de cette antinomie ?
-Il me semble
qu'elle est dans le fait
d'avoir caractérisé l'homme
comme un être qui pense...
et qui serait,
de ce fait, distinct
et radicalement
sur un autre plan
que tout le reste.
Il me semble
que c'est là
que l'antinomie
prend sa source.
D'une part,
parce qu'on peut
tout à fait contester
que la pensée, la raison,
la conscience de soi,
toutes les manifestations
de la pensée
soient d'un autre ordre
que dans l'ordre naturel.
Quand Aristote
qualifie l'homme
d'animal rationnel
ou d'animal doué de logos,
il l'inscrit dans l'ordre
du cosmos.
Donc pourquoi le fait de penser
mettrait l'homme
sur un plan
différent du reste ?
-Et on a prouvé qu'il y avait
une forme de pensée animale.
-J'allais y venir.
La deuxième chose,
c'est que réserver à l'homme
le privilège de la pensée
et en faire le fondement
de sa dignité inaliénable,
du même coup,
ça oblige à nier...
à nier toute forme de pensée
autre qu'humaine.
Il est là,
le noeud de l'antinomie.
C'est ça, d'ailleurs,
qui fait que...
Il y a quelque chose
de très nouveau, aussi,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui,
la question de l'humanité,
elle se pose beaucoup
à partir de ses marges.
C'est quelque chose
de très nouveau.
Il y a, je dirais,
deux marges :
la marge avec l'animalité
et la marge avec les intelligences
artificielles.
-Machine, ordinateur,
intelligence artificielle.
-Et d'un côté
comme de l'autre,
il y a un brouillage des frontières
qui se fait.
Effectivement,
énormément d'études scientifiques
montrent
qu'il y a des formes
de conscience de soi,
de pensée, de langage,
même de culture,
chez d'autres espèces
animales,
et qui obligent
à se réinterroger sur :
"Ben du coup,
"qu'est-ce que c'est
que l'humanité ?"
Et puis, de l'autre côté,
avec le développement
des intelligences
artificielles
et les perspectives
transhumanistes...
Avec le transhumanisme,
on parle bien
de dépasser quelque chose,
donc ça oblige à définir
la limite de ce que c'est
que d'être un humain.
Donc, de ce côté-là aussi,
la question de l'humanité
se pose à nouveau,
à partir de ces marges.
Ca, je crois
que c'est très nouveau.
-Si la définition
de l'humanité
ou si ce qui distingue
l'humanité du monde,
ça n'est pas la pensée,
puisque la machine,
comme l'animal, pense,
en quelque sorte,
qu'est-ce qui fait
la différence ?
-Je vais vous le dire
de manière un peu abrupte :
la différence, c'est l'ouverture
à la transcendance.
-Alors, il va falloir
nous expliquer ça.
C'est un retour au religieux ?
Est-ce que...
-Alors, ça oblige,
évidemment,
à préciser ce qu'on peut entendre
par transcendance.
Il me semble
qu'un des grands écueils
de la pensée actuelle
et de la philosophie
contemporaine,
est d'avoir un peu
trop vite évacué
la catégorie
de transcendance
de la rationalité
philosophique,
d'avoir laissé la catégorie
de transcendance
à la théologie,
mais du coup,
de l'avoir évacuée
du champ phénoménologique,
- et là on retrouve
le titre de l'ouvrage,
"Phénoménologie
de la transcendance".
-Un mot
sur la phénoménologie,
pour expliquer
en quoi ça consiste.
C'est une méthode...
-Oui, mais pour aller
très vite,
il y a aussi
une référence kantienne
dans cette méthode.
Kant montre
que nous n'avons accès
qu'au "champ de notre expérience
possible".
C'est le champ des phénomènes,
de ce qui nous apparaît,
de ce à quoi
nous avons accès
par la conscience.
Donc la phénoménologie,
c'est l'étude de ce champ
de l'expérience possible.
On trouve, chez Kant,
l'opposition
à la métaphysique, qui va
chercher à avoir accès
à ce qui est au-delà du champ
de l'expérience possible.
La phénoménologie ramène
la rationalité
dans le champ
de l'expérience possible.
-Vous montrez qu'on peut
faire l'expérience
d'une forme
de transcendance
sans verser dans le mysticisme,
car ce n'est pas
votre démonstration.
-On ne peut pas faire l'expérience
de la transcendance.
Par définition...
Puisque, par définition...
Je reviens peut-être
un instant, d'abord,
sur ce mot
de transcendance.
Pourquoi la transcendance
a été abandonnée
à la théologie ?
Parce que
la transcendance,
le terme même
de transcendance,
et c'est peut-être
le cas, là,
ou chez les spectateurs,
en voyant ce mot,
est tout de suite,
d'emblée,
associé
à des notions connexes
et en particulier
à la question de Dieu.
Voilà, quand on dit "transcendance",
à un moment donné,
entre la bouche et l'oreille
de l'auditeur,
ça se transforme
quelque part en "Dieu".
Ben non, là,
on ne parle pas de Dieu,
on parle de transcendance.
Elle est associée aussi
à tout un tas de superlatifs.
Transcendance,
c'est ce qui est
supérieur, l'être suprême,
un être suprême,
une supériorité
de puissance, etc.
Or je crois que,
très souvent,
quand on veut revenir
au sens d'un mot...
Il y a cette phrase
de Wittgenstein,
mise en exergue
dans mon livre :
parfois,
il faut prendre un mot,
le retirer de la langue
et le donner à nettoyer
pour pouvoir
le remettre en circulation.
Sur le mot de transcendance,
il faut faire ce travail,
de le nettoyer
de toutes les autres notions
qui se sont greffées dessus
et sédimentées.
Pour ça, on a un outil qui,
il me semble, est précieux,
qui est le passage
par les contraires.
"Transcendant",
ça s'oppose à quoi ?
Est-ce que ça s'oppose
à "inférieur" ?
Non, on ne dit pas...
Donc ça ne veut pas dire
"supérieur".
Est-ce que ça s'oppose
à "impuissant"? Non.
Donc ça veut pas dire
"puissant".
A quoi est-ce que ça s'oppose,
"transcendant" ?
Ca s'oppose à "immanent".
Le mot de "transcendance"
prend son sens
dans l'opposition
avec cet autre terme,
qui est celui d'immanence.
Et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire,
"immanent" ?
Ca veut dire,
tout simplement,
"quelque chose qui est
du même ordre que",
"du même ordre
qu'autre chose".
Et qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire,
à l'inverse,
"transcendant" ?
Ca veut dire "être d'un ordre
absolument autre que".
Mais "d'un ordre
absolument autre",
ça veut pas dire
"surpuissant",
"un être suprême", etc.
Ca veut juste dire
"d'un ordre autre".
D'ailleurs, c'est pas forcément
associé à Dieu.
Dieu peut être pensé comme
immanent ou transcendant.
Il y a plusieurs théologies.
Le panthéisme pense
un Dieu immanent.
Et on trouve aussi
des représentations
d'un Dieu transcendant.
Il n'y a donc
aucune raison d'associer
la catégorie de transcendance
à celle de Dieu.
Et moi,
ce que je propose,
ce que j'essaye de faire
dans mon travail,
c'est de décorréler
les deux
pour pouvoir réintégrer
la catégorie
de transcendance
dans une démarche strictement
phénoménologique.
Ceci étant dit,
pour répondre
à votre question,
on ne peut pas faire l'expérience
d'une transcendance,
tout simplement parce que,
par définition,
tout ce dont on peut faire
l'expérience
est de l'ordre
de notre expérience,
donc est immanent.
Donc on ne peut pas faire
l'expérience
de la transcendance.
En revanche,
on peut faire
l'expérience d'un monde.
On ne fait toujours que
l'expérience du monde.
Mais on peut faire
l'expérience
d'un monde
troué de transcendance,
et c'est comme ça
que je propose
d'appréhender la catégorie
de transcendance,
non pas comme
une surpuissance d'être,
mais comme un trou,
comme une brèche ouverte
dans l'être.
Et je crois que, voilà,
cette brèche
de transcendance,
c'est comme ça,
peut-être,
qu'on peut caractériser
le coeur
qui, du coup, est un coeur vide,
vous l'aurez compris,
de ce qui fait l'humanité.
-Comment on pourrait
l'appliquer,
si on voulait l'imaginer ?
Peut-être en revenant
à la question écologique ?
-En revenant
à la question écologique...
Je vais d'abord,
peut-être,
essayer de donner
un exemple,
pas directement lié
à la question écologique.
La transcendance,
c'est l'ouverture
de la pensée
à ce qui est absolument
d'un autre ordre
que le monde,
c'est-à-dire quelque chose
qui ne renvoie à rien
dans le monde.
Quand on dit par exemple,
tout simplement,
quelque chose comme
"Respecte ton prochain",
cet impératif-là,
ça n'est pas
quelque chose.
C'est pas comme si je dis :
"Ce fauteuil est noir".
Ca renvoie à quelque chose
dans le champ
de mon expérience.
"Respecte ton prochain",
c'est quelque chose
qui ne renvoie à rien,
à aucun être,
à rien, dans le champ
de mon expérience,
pas démontrable
scientifiquement,
pas perceptible par les sens,
et, pourtant,
c'est là,
et ça appelle,
c'est comme un appel d'air,
une aspiration,
un idéal qui appelle
une certaine forme d'action.
C'est cet appel d'air
que je propose d'envisager
sous la catégorie
de transcendance.
Donc...
Mais c'est la même chose.
Par exemple, on peut
appliquer cette catégorie
également
pour la création artistique.
Quand, face à un tableau de Vermeer,
on est, tout à coup,
saisi de quelque chose
qui nous transcende,
il s'agit pas
d'une puissance d'être.
On peut, face à un tableau
de Vermeer,
ne voir que des taches
de couleur.
C'est ça, si on en reste
au champ de l'immanence.
Mais il y a quelque chose
qui fait qu'un tableau de Vermeer
n'est pas réductible
à ces conditions de perception
phénoménologique.
Il ouvre quelque chose
dans l'être,
et c'est ça que je propose
d'appeler
la "transcendance".
C'est ce qu'on trouve,
par exemple,
chez Levinas,
avec l'expérience du visage,
qui n'est pas, chez Levinas,
l'assemblage, il le dit,
d'un nez, d'un front,
d'un menton et d'yeux.
Quand je rencontre
un visage,
je rencontre quelque chose
que je ne peux saisir,
qui n'est pas de l'être,
qui n'est pas
de la perception,
quelque chose qui s'ouvre,
une brèche ouverte
dans l'être.
Donc, pour en revenir
à la question écologique,
déjà, première chose :
ça nous invite
à repenser l'humanité
en sortant autrement
que dans cette tension
entre animal humain
ou transhumain.
Parce que là,
aujourd'hui,
on est pris dans ce choix
cauchemardesque
entre ces deux formes
d'humanité.
Ca nous permet
de redéfinir l'humanité
autrement
et de la redéfinir
non plus en termes
de progrès ou d'accumulation
de supériorité,
aller toujours
plus loin...
Mais en termes,
précisément,
d'une brèche ouverte
dans l'être. Et ça,
évidemment,
ça change complètement
le rapport
à l'autre homme,
le rapport au monde,
le rapport aux animaux aussi,
parce que,
quand on ne loge plus
l'humanité de l'homme
dans sa pensée,
il n'y a plus aucun problème
pour reconnaître
qu'il y a des formes de pensée
qui ne sont pas humaines,
des formes de pensée
animales,
des formes de conscience de soi
qu'il faut respecter
comme telles,
parce que ça ne remet plus
en question
ce qui fait le coeur de l'humanité.
Donc, ça change.
Ca change tout.
Donc... Voilà...
Ca ouvre, je crois,
une porte de sortie
de cette crise de paradigme
que nous traversons.
-Alors, on va terminer
cet entretien
par quelques questions.
Quel est le rôle du philosophe
dans la cité ?
Est-il roi, ermite,
ou conseiller du prince ?
-Alors, pour moi,
ni l'un, ni l'autre,
ni l'autre !
Si je devais
définir le rôle du philosophe
dans la cité,
je dirais que le philosophe
est un briseur d'idoles.
Je crois que
chaque individu,
chaque génération,
chaque époque
a ses idoles, et ces idoles,
c'est précisément
ces idées, devenues idoles,
figées en idoles,
qu'on n'interroge plus,
qu'on ne remet plus
en question,
ces idéologies.
Voilà, on voit,
on sent une proximité entre "idée",
"idole" et "idéologie".
Il y a dans la philosophie
quelque chose
qui est toujours à recommencer,
qui est, précisément,
de venir ébranler,
de venir briser
les idoles de son temps,
ce qui fait que,
finalement...
C'est quand même paradoxal
que le père de la philosophie,
Socrate, soit un homme
qui n'ait jamais rien dit,
qui n'ait aucune doctrine,
qui n'ait fait qu'une chose,
qui est, justement,
de briser les idoles
de son temps,
de tout mettre en question.
Il l'a payé
assez cher.
Le philosophe,
c'est un empêcheur
de tourner en rond,
donc il dérange,
il n'arrête pas
de déranger,
il ébranle,
et en même temps,
en empêchant
de tourner en rond,
du coup, c'est lui aussi
qui permet d'avancer.
Parce que, pour avancer,
il faut,
à un moment donné,
être ébranlé
dans ses certitudes.
Il faut...
Avancer, ça veut dire,
à un moment, prendre le risque
de s'ébranler,
de se mettre
en déséquilibre,
pour pouvoir aller
vers autre chose.
Et je crois...
Voilà, je dirais
que c'est peut-être ça,
le rôle du philosophe
dans la cité.
-Si vous deviez citer
le grand livre
de philosophie ?
Allez, "les",
pour être généreuse.
-C'est très compliqué,
ce que vous me demandez,
mais je vais
le faire en lien
avec ce que je disais juste avant.
C'est-à-dire que,
pour moi,
la puissance philosophique
d'un livre est justement
dans sa puissance
d'ébranlement.
Qu'est-ce que le livre
va ébranler chez moi ?
Donc c'est toujours aussi
une rencontre,
car il faut être
réceptif et ouvert
pour se laisser ébranler.
C'est difficile de répondre
à cette question,
car à différents moments,
différents textes.
Mais peut-être
les deux préfaces
à la "Critique de la raison pure"
de Kant.
Par ordre chronologique,
les "Méditations
métaphysiques",
le 1er livre de "L'éthique"
de Spinoza
et les 2 préfaces à la "Critique
de raison pure" de Kant.
-Descartes, Spinoza, Kant.
-Le trio...
-Comment pourriez-vous
formuler
- question
particulièrement difficile,
en termes de synthèse -
en une phrase,
la grande question philosophique
d'aujourd'hui ?
-Ca ne va peut-être pas
vous surprendre,
mais je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui,
pour moi,
la grande question,
c'est justement d'arriver
à se faire les gardiens
de cette brèche
de transcendance
ouverte dans l'être
que représente l'humanité,
de se faire les gardiens
de cette brèche,
parce qu'il n'y a rien
de plus fragile
et de plus précieux
qu'une brèche ouverte,
si elle se referme
complètement,
si on ne voit plus,
dans un tableau de Vermeer,
que des taches de couleur,
si on ne voit plus,
dans un visage,
qu'un assemblage d'un nez
et de traits plastique,
alors, là, je crois
qu'on sera vraiment,
vraiment rentrés dans un monde
vraiment cauchemardesque.
-Merci beaucoup.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA